[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to the joy of
physics in this video I'm not going to
use any mathematical equations and I
hope it will be fairly simple to follow
I'm going to talk about rainbows and how
they are formed whilst drawing some
artwork on the board so I hope you stay
to follow along with me I'll start with
drawing in the sky here some dark blue
clouds mixed with highlights of white
rainbows are really the most amazing
thing a beautiful decoration on the sky
I will always want to stop and look at a
rainbow if I happen to see one the
physics behind a rainbow has been fairly
well understood since Newton's time but
it wasn't until I did some extra
research for this video that I think I
really understood I knew it was
something to do with refraction and
reflection of light within water
droplets but I kind of left my
explanation at that today I hope to help
you properly see rainbows and learn more
about them rainbow is caused by sunlight
always appear in the section of sky
directly opposite the Sun we need the
Sun then us and in front of us we need
some water droplets commonly delivered
in the form of rain so rainbows are
usually seen in the early morning or
late afternoon when we can line all of
those components up it's not usually
raining beneath your feet at midday so
you wouldn't normally see a rainbow then
but you might a few perhaps use a hose
so I'm not drawing the Sun in my picture
today since it would be behind me I'm
just drawing some nice
clouds in here with a little sunlight
highlighting them it was Isaac Newton
friend of the channel who took a glass
prism and used it to study the way that
white light from the Sun can split into
a spectrum of colors Newton filled his
room with colorful patterns of light
this way and you would have seen such
things in your everyday life maybe the
way light comes through a window or
glass ornament and streaks colors across
your room why don't I pause my landscape
there for a moment and show you this
giant raindrop now we might be used to
drawing raindrops as tear shaped perhaps
because when a water droplet falls down
a glass window or that's here falls down
our face it is tear shaped because
friction with the glass or with our skin
drags some of the water up into a tail
but an air friction is actually much
less and falling raindrops are spherical
this is the cross-section of a water
droplet that I painted earlier now light
when it hits a medium like water or
glass and slow down and Bend light from
the Sun is made up of all the colors of
the rainbow and these colors will each
bend a different amount which gives our
first tiny rainbow in here with blue
light bending more than red at this
interface some of the light will also be
reflected off the droplet and never come
inside and our second boundary over here
some of the light will exit the droplet
and speed up as it goes back into air
but some be reflected again at our third
interface here again some of the light
will exit and this exiting light here
will be the primary rainbow that we see
but some light will continue to bounce
around inside of the droplet if the
light had been incident in the middle
here it would have gone straight
through if it had come in right at the
top here it would have followed a
different path and come out somewhere
over here the path that I have drawn is
a path where the angle between the
incident light and the exiting red light
is 42 degrees this happens to be the
maximum exit angle for the red light and
also its maximum intensity the red light
can't exit out anywhere over here this
is its maximum angle so it can come out
here or anywhere in here the other
colors all have their own maximum
intensity and maximum exit angles and
they are slightly less than the red
because our raindrop is spherical and
because light from the Sun is incident
at all of those angles at the same time
there will be a ring of incident angles
like that one I just showed you the
result of that is that we will end up
from a single water droplet having a
cone of red light at 42 degrees the
maximum exit angle for blue light was
lower around 40 degrees so that cone
would be a little smaller with all the
other colors in between from one water
droplet we will end up with a circular
ring of rainbow with white in the middle
where all of the different colors are
mixing together but this is not what we
would see our eyes are pretty small and
we only see the light that reaches them
if this one water droplet was directly
in front of me and all I was seeing was
the light from the center then what I
would see would just be white light if
this one water droplet was above me say
at an angle of 42 degrees from my eyes
all I would see would be red light if it
was slightly lower all I would see would
be orange light with maybe a hint of red
lower again I would see yellow green
blue indigo and violet and this is the
important part of the explanation a
rainbow that we see
is not just one water droplet splitting
light into colors but it is the result
of many water droplets working together
I will see red light from an arc of
water droplets in the sky all 42 degrees
away from my eye and likewise with the
other colors I will see an orange arc or
yellow or a green or a blue arc from all
of the water droplets that are in just
the right place and just the right angle
from my eye to show me that intensity of
color one droplet alone makes a rainbow
cone but like all things in life we can
achieve more if we work together to see
a rainbow we are seeing the combined
effort of millions maybe even trillions
of water droplets but maybe you have
high expectations and think that
trillions of raindrops ought to achieve
more than just one rainbow and well you
would be right there is never just one
rainbow everyone gets their own unique
rainbow if I had a friend standing next
to me she would see a different rainbow
formed by the raindrops that happen to
be at the correct and yellow direction
to send the different colors of light
into her eyes so just like people every
rainbow is unique the colors of the
rainbow are continuous but for the
purpose of drawing them we usually split
them up into seven distinct bands Newton
divided his spectrum up into seven
colors to which he liked because of an
ancient Greek belief that there was a
connection between the colors and
musical notes and known objects in the
solar system which must have been seven
at a time and the days of the week this
indigo we speak of looks suspiciously
like dark blue to me but each to their
own the question of whether everyone
sees seven colors in a row
bow is related to the idea of linguistic
relativity you might think that everyone
perceives a rainbow in the same way
perhaps the number of distinct colors
observed and what these are called
depend on the language one uses with
people whose language has fewer color
words seeing fewer discreet bands
holding some research that suggests that
in the description it's just a little
reminder that we all perceive reality a
little differently it is kind of true
that we can't really see the full
rainbow unseeing red light from the
droplets all 42 degrees away from my eye
but the full set of droplets that match
that description would make a ring
however about half of that ring is
blocked off by the horizon so we only
see a rainbow from the droplets that not
only meet the right angle but are also
in the sky because of this we do perhaps
miss out on seeing the full beauty of
the rainbow but perhaps it is also a
case of less is more as I draw in these
trees here I try to remember that this
is sometimes more and I'll try not to go
overboard if you could see a rainbow
from above with the Sun behind you then
you would see a full circle I had known
that fact for a while and I was once on
a plane flying into Wellington which is
a very windy city and I'm an anxious
flier so it's not the most fun to land
there but I looked out the window and
could see a rainbow ring around the
plane I thought this must be a rainbow
from above and I was really excited but
according to a Google search I did the
other day it was actually something
called a glory rather than a rainbow
from above glories are smaller and the
result of diffraction of light within
the
that doesn't mean it wasn't awesome
because glories are their own special
and magic kind of physics but it wasn't
the rainbow from above that I thought it
was that would be a lot larger I'm just
giving this happy little tree here some
friends to hang out with another
phenomenon is the 22 degree halo which
appears around the Sun or moon unlike a
rainbow which would appear opposite in
the sky halos are the result of ice
crystals rather than water droplets so
at least I now know not to call any of
these other things rainbows even though
they are just as inspiring I would like
to be a rainbow hunter I don't know if
that kind of person exists but the idea
of going around looking for different
types of rainbows seems really nice to
me a bit more chill than being a storm
chaser I love the idea of geometric
optics it's something that's kind of
understandable but also still built on
complex ideas it's beautiful and
inspiring it's a branch of physics that
explained something that we all find
wonderful the sky inside a primary
rainbow is brighter than the sky outside
of the bow because of that mixing of a
little of every color the light here is
being hugged by a rainbow and how nice
is that so I'll make it a little bit
whiter on my artwork here now we didn't
forget about our light friend who was
still reflecting around inside of the
water droplet and it will eventually
emerge from the droplet forming a second
rainbow which you can sometimes spot
since it has been reflected again the
colors will be in the opposite order and
the white light will be on the exterior
not interior leading to a dark band
between the two bows called
Alexander's band
we lose some light at each reflection
and the second rainbow is spread over a
larger part of sky so the second rainbow
will always be fainter than the first
I don't theory is always there it's
usually too faint to see though there
will also be higher-order rainbows such
as from a third or fourth reflection but
these are very rare to see unless you're
trying to reconstruct them in a lab and
in that case you might have a bit more
luck it's just another reminder that
behind every bright person we see there
are often other people like their
friends and family supporting them even
if you can't always see them no rainbows
are alone their friends are just a
little shy now it's not all just simple
reflection the very nature of quantum
mechanics is even peeking through in a
rainbow because of very small droplets
less than one millimeter across
sometimes a narrow faintly colored bands
can be seen near the violet edge of a
rainbow these are called supernumerary
bows and cannot be explained by
classical geometric objects but rather
that they are caused by the interference
between rays of light following slightly
different paths with slightly varying
lengths within the raindrops this
interference was one of the first
indications of the wave nature of light
and first explained by Thomas Young in
1804 I'll add in some birds and some
stars and planets to our sky here to
make it feel a little more magical the
double rainbow is not the only curious
variation that a rainbow hunter could
find at sunset or sunrise when only red
light is in the sky we can see an
entirely red rainbow
night the moon may illuminate a moonbow
groups of different sized raindrops may
lead to twinned rainbows which are side
by side perhaps the coolest thought of
all is that rainbows probably exist
elsewhere in the solar system on
Saturn's moon Titan there is a very wet
surface with humid clouds of mostly
methane and I wonder how a methane
rainbow would look I find that a very
inspiring thought and I think we'll call
that finished thank you for staying with
me to the end of the video I hope you
have an absolutely mathematical day and
if you're interested in learning more
about the physics in the world around us
then check out this video sponsor
brilliant you can set a goal to improve
your scientific knowledge and trip away
at it every day
brilliant makes that possible with
interactive explorations and a mobile
app so that you can learn wherever you
are their course on waves and light will
work up your knowledge to understanding
more optical phenomena heads to
brilliant not org slash Tibby's the link
is below and the first 200 people to do
so will get 20% off their annual
subscription you can always give the
gift of knowledge to buy a gifting
premium to someone else
thanks to brilliant and thanks to my
patreon supporters for making this video
possible including today's patreon cat
of the day mini thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you